The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Why don't
we go ahead and get started,
folks.
Just some small talk
to get us started.
I promise to tell you the
stories about contamination
and unintentional contamination.
Before we dive in,
what a life, right?
Steve Jobs.
That was really something.
Moments like that, I think
the best you can possibly do
is to celebrate the person.
And well, in honor
of his inventiveness
and the way he really
turned Apple around,
I just wanted to focus
a minute on that.
Speaking of contamination and
unintentional contamination,
the effect on processing,
the history books
are full of this
folklore, if you
start talking to people
who grow crystals
and who manufacture solar cells.
The growth of the crystals
that are used to actually make
the wafers that ultimately
wind up being solar cells
is a little bit of
a-- how would you
say-- a little bit of an art.
It is being codified
rather well now.
And there's some strong
science behind it.
But by and large,
up to very recently,
it was more of an
art than a science.
The best crystal growers are
people who are very observant
it and who are able to look
out and see correlations
where they weren't
immediately visible to others.
So in one particular
factory, they
started noticing that they had
yield losses during the winter
time.
And in particular they
had extreme yield losses
whenever there was
a big snowstorm.
And it was somebody, one of
the shift leads, I believe,
who traced it back
to the salt that
was marching in
on people's boots
as they were coming
into the factory.
And that sodium was
contaminating the silicon melt
and resulting in the poor
quality of the crystals that
were being grown.
Flash forward several years
at Fraunhofer Institute
for Solar Energy Systems
in Freiburg, Germany
where the observant cell
manufacture started noticing,
well, gee, our efficiencies
are always lower on Fridays.
Why is that?
And eventually, they traced
the problem down to the fact
that, on Fridays,
the technicians
would go out to lunch
at a Chinese restaurant.
And they would come back, and
their breath and their hands
would be MSG.
And that was, again,
the sodium was downing
performance of the devices.
As so it's really interesting.
This kind of sounds like
something you might see in a TV
show where that scientist in
the lab coat waltzes into a room
and says, it must be the sodium.
Right?
And then they test it.
And oh, my gosh,
it's the sodium.
Now, problem solving
the real world
doesn't quite happen that way.
It involves a very
methodical approach
to testing a variety
of hypotheses,
first brainstorming in
a structured manner,
identifying the most
likely candidates,
and going about
solving the problem,
performing a series
of design experiments
to really get to the root cause.
So it's an interesting story.
It's an interesting aside.
Solving contamination problems,
though, is very difficult.
And the best thing
you can possibly
do if you're growing
crystals is to keep
your system more clean than
you think you need it to be.
That's the best
advice I can give.
I was just talking with some
folks in Caltech the other day.
They were running into
contamination issues.
And that advice goes a long way.
OK.
Well, let's go ahead and get
started in the topic today.
Back from Phoenix and eyes are
red from irritation of having
been awake for too many hours.
So that could only
mean one thing.
Contacts, right?
So we're going to be talking
about contacts today,
charge extraction, as well.
And to situate us
on the roadmap,
we have our
fundamentals right here.
We're about to jump forward
into the technology, which
is really exciting.
We're about out of
the woods here, folks.
And finally, into the
cross-cutting themes.
And so, again, every
photovoltaic device
must obey this general
equation right here
where the output energy
over the input energy
equals a conversion efficiency.
And for most solar cells, this
is represented by this right
here.
And we have now tackled every
single one of those, at least
in a very fundamental way.
And now, finally, we are focused
on the output, the charge
collection, in other words,
the contacting of the device.
Again, the total
cell efficiency is
going to be the product of
each of these individual cell
efficiencies here.
And contacts are a
very, very easy way
to kill your device
in a variety of ways.
And we'll get to some of
these points right here.
As a matter of
fact, this s back,
this surface
recombination velocity
on the backside
of the device, is
a contact-related phenomenon.
And that's exactly where
the water is spilling out
of this bucket right here.
Learning objectives.
The idea is to start
out with describing
the purpose of contacts,
and their most common types,
then to describe the impact
of good and poor contacts
on I-V characteristics,
in other words,
to describe the device
impact of contacts.
So we're convinced
that this is really
something we should be spending
a lot of time thinking about.
Then we're going to sketch the
I-V characteristics of Schottky
and Ohmic contacts.
We'll learn what those mean.
I hope you know
what ohmic means.
Describe what fundamental
material parameters determine
I-V characteristics of a
contact/semiconductor junction,
sketch common band alignments,
and sketch common solar cell
device architectures,
once we're done.
And then we can look back and
gaze over the fundamentals
and say, Ha, ha,
how far we've come.
And now that you look
at a solar cell device,
hopefully, you'll look at it
in a much more profound way
than you did in the
first day of class.
The more you know,
the more you see.
So contacts, why
do we need them?
We need to extract the
carriers from the device.
We need to prevent the
back-diffusion of carriers
into the device.
These contacts, in general, have
been studied very extensively
in the semiconductor industry.
Why is that?
Why do we need contacts in
the semiconductor industry
to make integrated circuits?
Obvious answer.
We need wires.
We need to extract the charges
from our transistors, right?
So we're injecting charge,
pulling out charge.
So contacts have been
pretty extensively studied
in the semiconductor industry.
And we're going to
leverage that a lot.
We're not going to reinvent the
wheel where we don't need to.
Contacts are
semiconductor-specific.
Fundamentals apply
broadly, but the specifics
pertain to-- or the devil's in
the details, in other words.
So there are very
specific effects
that occur, depending on the
precise semiconductor metal
combination.
And lastly, the
contacts are heavily
influenced by the interface
between the semiconductor
and the metal.
We're going to be talking
about that as well.
So typical materials
used for contacts
include metals, transparent
conducting oxides.
And also, we can find heavily
doped organic materials
as well.
Metals, we understand.
OK, they're optically opaque
and electrically conductive.
That means they conduct
electricity very nicely.
And so our series resistance
along the metal wire
should be low.
But they're optically
opaque, meaning they're
resulting in a shading loss.
So if we cover entire
front side with metal,
we're not going to have a
very efficient solar cell,
because our absorption of
light is going to be very poor.
On the other hand,
transparent conducting oxides
are optically transparent and
electrically conductive, not
quite as conductive as
metals, but pretty close.
So let me think about
that for a minute.
A material that is
optically transparent--
that means it must have
a very large band gap
to let the light through,
does interact with it,
but is electrically conductive.
In other words, it has a high
concentration of free carriers
that can move around the
material and conduct charge.
How is that possible?
I hope you're asking
that question,
because this perplexed me
for a long time as well.
And we'll answer that
in a couple of slides.
First, the properties of TCOs.
What makes a transparent
conducting oxide a transparent
conducting oxide?
I figure I'll spend a couple
slides on this, since metals
are pretty self-evident.
But TCOs, this might
be the first time
you're encountering them.
They're present in a
variety of devices.
If you have an iPhone,
or if you've ever
seen certain types of military
aircraft, TCOs are involved.
So the material is
very transparent.
You can see the transparency
over quite a broad wavelength
range here, cutting off only
in the several eV range here.
Transparency begins to
drop, because you're
able to excite carries
across the band gap.
So it's a very large
band gap material,
and yet, the conductivity
is very good.
So here, we can see that the
conductivity of ITO, that's
indium tin oxide, that's a
particular type of transparent
conducting oxide, is
almost as good as silver.
Not quite, but it's
approaching it.
And so again, the conductivity,
which is 1 over the resistivity
is related to the carrier
concentration and the mobility,
as we've seen before.
And therefore, there must
be a lot of free carriers.
And they must be fairly mobile,
to move around the material.
So how does that work?
Band gap greater than 3.1
eV, transmittance very high,
as a result, but still a
large number of carriers.
Well, if we consider our
band gap right here--
and we'll consider floating
Fermi energy right now,
we'll explain why that's
pegged there in a minute--
we assume that the
band gap is very large,
so that light can go through,
and it's optically transparent.
But now, by doping the material
with a specific type of dopant
that forms mid-gap
states, we're going
to create a new energy level
here that is partially filled.
We can then excite, with
relatively little energy,
carriers into the excited
states within that orange band,
and they can transport charge
throughout the material.
On the other hand, if we
come in with a high energy
photon or a moderate
energy photo,
let's say, in the
visible, it doesn't
have quite enough energy to
excite from that orange band
into the conduction band,
nor from the valence band
into the orange band, the
intermediate band there.
And that's the general principle
of how transparent conducting
oxides function.
You can have indium doped
tin oxide, for instance, ITO,
as a classic example.
And this is the basic premise.
Any questions so far, because
this is kind of important,
before we launch into-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how big
are those, that E1, E2?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yeah.
So this E3 right here is around
0.4 eV, for a typical TCO.
And E1 and E2, the
sum of both of them
could be on the order
of three to four eV.
Maybe higher.
Well actually, no.
Sorry.
Just one of these
transitions right
here could be on the
order of three eV.
So the entire band gap
could be quite large.
If you think of metal
oxides-- most metal oxides
have very large band gaps.
And most TCOs fall
into that category.
They could be tin
oxide or zinc oxide,
but heavily doped
with an element,
like indium, or
fluorine, or aluminum,
to provide that
intermediate band.
AUDIENCE: What are the doping
concentrations required
[INAUDIBLE]?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yes.
So this is a deep dive,
and I'm happy to entertain
that question.
For those who it kind
of goes over your head,
don't worry about it.
We'll return, so plant
a flag post in your mind
where we're at.
Remember the hydrogenic donor
model for a dopant atom.
You introduce it
into the lattice.
And that loosely bound
electron is there, kind of
like a hydrogenic donor.
It has a certain radius.
And if you begin doping at
a very high concentration,
those electrons will begin
interfering with each other.
They'll begin interacting.
And so instead of forming
one isolated defect level,
they'll start splitting
and forming a band.
And the density at
which you have to dope
depends on that donor radius.
So you're typically talking
about concentrations in the 10
to the 20 per cubic centimeter,
or one atomic percent
or higher.
So that's the dopant
density that's
required to force
this transition.
It's pretty cool.
I mean, there are people who
do their PhDs on transparent
conducting oxides.
Maybe some of you are.
You could probably come up
and give a lecture about it.
So it's a fascinating subject.
And because ITO, or
indium tin oxide,
is just so amazing in
terms of its conductivity--
it's almost up there
buttressing again
silver-- it's very difficult
to replace with something else.
Zinc oxide and its
variants get pretty close,
like aluminum dope zinc
oxide, sometimes called
AZO in the PV community.
They get pretty
close, but they're not
quite as good in terms
of optical transparency
and conductivity as ITO.
Now ITO is a problem.
It contains indium.
And the world supply
of indium is limited.
It's not the most abundant
element on the Earth's crust.
If you look at a periodic table,
it's pretty far down there.
And as you know, the
elemental abundance,
it has a relative decay
from-- a power law
decay-- from light
elements to heavy elements
with some fluctuations
in between.
But in general, the star
dust that we have here
is less abundant in
the heavier elements.
And indium is one
of those elements.
And so people are searching
for alternatives to ITO.
And it's an active area
of research right now.
OK.
So for now, let's go
back to the flag post
that we planted just
a few minutes ago.
For everyone who
didn't quite follow
the detailed explanation, the
important thing to keep in mind
is that TCOs are
conductive and transparent.
And they are so, because of
the unique band structure.
So we can create contacts
to semiconductors
and extract charge using
either a metal or a TCO.
And right now,
we're going to dive
into the impact of good
and bad contacts on device
characteristics.
So during our last-- I believe
it was two lectures ago,
we talked about the
equivalent circuit diagram
of a solar cell, this being the
simplest case, now corrected
with our minus 1
term right here.
And we can see our I-V curve in
linear, linear scale and log,
linear scale there, log
current linear voltage.
And because this
is an exponential,
you would expect
a straight line,
and you do see that indeed.
Now the I-V curve,
in the upper part,
you can really see
has a very nice fill
factor as a very sharp kink.
Pops straight up.
And so the fill factor of that
I-V curve, when illuminated,
will be very high.
And hence, the solar cell
efficiency will be high.
Not so when you introduce
a series resistance.
So when you have that
series resistance component,
now, at higher
bias voltages, you
begin to be series
resistance limited,
which causes the fill
factor to decrease.
And you can see that
by going back and forth
between these two slides.
High fill factor, no
series resistance.
Lower fill factor,
higher series resistance.
Especially, if you focus right
here at this point right there,
you can really see the
decrease of fill factor
as a result of adding a
series resistance component.
So contacts, when
improperly performed,
can add a series resistance
component, a rather significant
one, and drop the
performance of your device.
Likewise, shunt resistance.
We saw a simple effect right
here of shunt resistance.
If the shunt resistance
goes down further
and the saturation current
goes up even higher,
it begins to affect the
fill factor as well.
And so shunting can also
be impacted by contacts.
Particularly when you fire your
contacts, in other words when
you heat your sample up,
or you heat your stack up
to create good contact between
the metal and the semiconductor
underneath, or the TCO and
the semiconductor underneath,
a couple of things can happen.
If you don't get the chemistry
just right at the interface--
maybe didn't clean
your sample properly,
maybe you didn't heat
it up high enough,
so that the atoms really started
to interdiffuse and interact--
you can under-fire your contact.
And that results in poor
contact with your semiconductor
and large series resistance.
So large series resistance
will, essentially,
impede charge flow and
result in a fill factor loss.
On the other hand,
if you over-fire
your contact-- let's
say you heat it up,
but fire it a little too long--
then the contact material
can drive too far into
your semiconductor,
and you wind up
shunting your device.
What does a shunt mean?
A shunt mean that the metal
goes straight through the PN
junction and contacts the base
material on the other side.
So remember, the PN junction
region of the solar cell
is only about a micron
away from the surface.
It's really close.
So if you have a fast diffusing
metal species and you heat it
up too much, you get the
metal going straight through,
in this case, the
n+ layer into the P,
you'll shunt your device.
So this is the fine
balance that you
have to walk when
you're putting contact
metallization on the device.
You can't over-fire it,
because we wind up with shunts.
You can't under-fire
it either, because you
might wind up with a very
large contact resistance.
So it's a very tricky
thing to get right.
We just finished installing a
contact metallization printer
in our lab.
And Joe, how many
human hours total
have been spent trying to
optimize the firing process?
JOE: Probably
about 30 or 40 now?
TONIO BUONASSISI: 30
or 40 human hours?
So it's still a
work in progress,
but it takes a while
to really nail that.
Yes, Ashley?
ASHLEY: So would
you want your TCO
to melt at a lower temperature
that your semiconductor?
Is that another consideration?
TONIO BUONASSISI: So
let's back up a step.
For the metal case, it's
pretty straightforward.
This is a homogeneous element.
Let's call it a unary material,
meaning one element comprising
that metal, typically.
And it's very simple for us
to see, OK, if we keep it up
and it reacts with our
material, it drives in.
For a TCO, it's a little
less straightforward,
because you typically
have a multinary compound,
meaning several elements
comprising your TCO.
The formation of this
intermediate band
right here that forms, really,
the conductivity of the TCO,
is predicated upon
the principle that you
have these dopant atoms
homogeneously spaced
throughout your material.
If you heat it up
too high and they
begin to cluster,
in other words,
precipitate out of
phase, you can wind up
destroying your TCO, or
increasing the resistivity,
maybe even decreasing
the optical transparency.
And so it really is
material-specific
when we start
talking about TCOs.
I'd rather not
generalize about them.
About metals is more
straightforward.
ASHLEY: OK.
I guess then, for
metals, you would
have to choose a metal that
melts before your semiconductor
melt-- or [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI:
Typically, you wouldn't have
your mental melting, per se.
What you're looking for is
a chemical reaction here
at this interface.
You're looking for
the metal, most often,
to form a binary compound
between your metal
and the semiconducting
material underneath.
Let's say you have
nickel and silicon.
You'd be looking for it
to form a nickel silicide
at that interface.
ASHLEY: OK.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
And that's where
you go to your phase
diagrams and figure out
what temperature those, say,
intermetallics should form.
And then you're targeting
that particular temperature
during your ramp.
ASHLEY: OK.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
And of course, it's
not only phase
diagrams which are
under equilibrium conditions,
kinetics are involved as well.
So it becomes a
rather tricky process.
Yeah, question in the back.
AUDIENCE: This
picture is drawn where
it says doping is concentrated
underneath [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yep.
AUDIENCE: How do we
manage to concentrate
the dopant in just that
certain section [INAUDIBLE]?
TONIO BUONASSISI:
Very good question.
So we'll explain toward
the end of lecture
why dopant is concentrated
underneath there.
For those who are a
little bit more advanced,
it relates to a tunneling
junction effect or a field
emission effect.
But we'll explain what
that is for everyone else.
The way you typically get an
enhanced dopant concentration
right underneath the
metal, first, let's
appreciate the length
scales involved here.
The width of that
contact metal is probably
on the order of
somewhere between,
let's say, 80 and 120
microns, maybe a little more.
And so, at those
length scales, we
don't need photo
lithography to really nail
a particular location.
We're not talking about
tens of nanometers.
It's really something
more macroscopic.
So we can do it in a few ways.
On the high end, we could
use an ion implantation tool
to pattern our
material with a mask.
On the low end, we might diffuse
in the emitter very deeply,
to create a highly doped
region everywhere, and then
create a mask using not exactly
a photo lithography process.
It could be a much simpler
contacting process,
and then etch away some of
the emitter in other regions
to make it more lightly doped
or, even in silicon's case,
create a poor silicon
layer and etch that off,
to distinguish between
the heavily doped
and the lightly doped regions.
There are a few different
ways to skin that cat.
And that's one of the beauties
of solar cell processing
is that it really pertains
to the specific material
system involved.
But the length scales are
such that you're really
not typically limited
by photolithography.
You can probably get around
that and use other techniques
for masking it off.
Mm-hm.
Great.
I see folks are awake today,
despite the P-set due.
Sketch the I-V characteristics
of Schottky and Ohmic contacts.
OK, so what we're
going to do here
is talk about how Schottky and
Ohmic contacts come into being.
And first off, define them.
So let's define them.
An Ohmic contact is one in
which I sweep my voltage,
and I obtain a linear
current response.
So this is pretty
straightforward.
It's Ohm's law, follows
Ohm's law, so V equals IR.
This is a linear
relationship then
between voltage and
current, the slope of which
is dictated by the resistance.
A Schottky contact,
on the other hand,
follows this beautiful
exponential curve
that we've come to know and love
from our ideal diode equation.
As a matter of fact, it
follows that same expression
rather nicely.
There's an exponential relation
between voltage and current.
So whenever we have an
exponential relation
between voltage and
current, now that we
know how a PN
junciton works, and we
recall that it's really that
diffusion current that's
driving the forward
current right here
under forward bias conditions.
We've learned that, when
the barrier's too large,
the electrons just
can't make it over.
But as a barrier
begins dropping,
an exponentially increasing
number of electrons
can jump over that
barrier and move
from the region of
high concentration
to the region of
low concentration,
or from the n-type material
to the p-type material.
So when we see an exponential
current voltage response,
we should immediately think
about some barrier involved
in our system.
And as we begin
biasing this device--
in this case, a semiconductor
metal junction--
as we begin biasing the
semiconductor versus the metal,
we begin seeing an
exponential current response.
We should imagine
that there must
be some barrier in between the
metal and the semiconductor.
And we'll explain how that
barrier comes into being.
So again, just to recap, making
sure we hit all the points.
Ohmic, a linear I-V curve.
And Ohmic contacts
are typically used
when charge separation
is not the goal
for your metallization.
Let's say you've already
achieved your charge separation
through the PN junction,
and now, you just
want to contact
your semiconductor
to extract the charge,
you'd use an Ohmic contact.
But you would use
a Schottky contact
when you want to enforce
some charge separation.
Typically, not quite
as good as, say,
a PN junction for
separating charge,
not quite as high voltage.
But it's a useful tool,
for example, in research.
So we're going to describe
what fundamental material
parameters determine the
I-V characteristics of both
the Ohmic and Schottky
junctions, more generally,
a contact
semiconductor junction.
And this dives into
Schottky band theory.
This is a very idealized
version of the real world.
It's an idealized
version, because it
gets us started and points
us in the right direction.
Then we'll add
layers of complexity,
until we build up
to really understand
what's going on inside
of these devices.
So let's start here.
This is a very nice, elegant
view of contact theory.
We have our
semiconductor over here.
Let's walk through this.
So this is our
energy band diagram.
We have E on the
vertical axis that
represents the energy
of the electron,
versus X, some real
space parameter.
We have our semiconductor
material here.
We have our valence band,
our conduction band,
and our Fermi energy.
This looks to be an n-type
semiconducting material.
And we have our vacuum level.
The vacuum level is
essentially the energy
at which we remove an electron
from the semiconductor.
If the semiconductor were
placed, let's say, in a vacuum,
and we were to excite an
electron out of the material
through some, let's say,
a photoemission effect,
we would have to overcome
the energy between the Fermi
energy and the vacuum level.
This xi right here is
essentially the electron
affinity of the semiconductor.
That's the delta in
energy, or q times xi
is the delta in energy
between the vacuum
level and the conduction band.
So we have all of the
variables mapped out
for the semiconductor.
Most of them should be
familiar for us already.
We've added the vacuum
level for completeness.
The metal, we also
have a Fermi energy,
we also a chemical
potential of the metal.
And we have a work function
of the metal, right here.
So this work function
is defined as the energy
necessary to remove an
electron from the metal.
Say again, by if you shined
a light on the material,
it has a high enough energy,
you can begin exciting electrons
off of the metal with
a photoemission effect.
And so we have our vacuum levels
in this particular diagram
lined up.
And our chemical
potentials are a little bit
different between the metal
and the semiconductor.
So what do you think will happen
when we put the two together?
If we put the two together,
the chemical potential
throughout the entire system
has to be the same, right?
Because now, they're in good
contact with one another.
But what about
that vacuum level?
What's going to happen?
Will there be
discontinuity, first of all,
in the vacuum level?
Can there be a discontinuity
If I move one little delta
x from the semiconductor
into the metal,
do I expect there
to be a discontinuity
in the vacuum level?
No, probably not.
So there has to be some smooth
change in the vacuum energy,
relative to the Fermi energy.
And if the vacuum
level changes, that
means that the conduction
band and valence band energies
are also going to change,
relative to the Fermi energy,
because the valence band
and conduction band energies
track with the vacuum level--
the vacuum level being defined
as the amount of energy
necessary to remove
the electron from the system.
So what you get when you
put these two materials
together is something
like this right here.
This dashed blue line
representing the Fermi energy,
or the chemical potential
throughout the entire system,
is the same.
In this particular case,
we didn't bias our device.
We're not applying a
battery or some bias voltage
between one side and the other.
So we have the same chemical
potential throughout.
If we have the same chemical
potential throughout,
notice that we had
to push this up,
or push the Fermi
energy up, to reach--
and of course, the work function
in the metal's not changing,
and so the vacuum
energy also goes up.
But since there can't be a
discontinuity in the vacuum
energy, you see a little
bit of a rise of the vacuum
energy in the semiconductor.
And of course, the valence band
and conduction bands follow.
And that results
in this little rise
right here, right
next to the interface
between the semiconductor
and the metal.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a discontinuity
in the first derivative
of the vacuum level?
Is there a kink in it?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Ha.
A very interesting question.
So typically, we draw it
as having a discontinuity
in the first derivative.
We would draw a very sharp
interface right there.
But in a practical sense,
I'll reserve judgment
on that, until I think a little
bit more deeply about it.
It's difficult for me to
believe that there would be,
if you zoom in very, very
closely, very finely.
The bending, let's think
about it from another way,
from what we already know.
This is essentially
the second integral
of the charge distribution
across that interface.
And if the charge distribution
is sharp enough, sure,
I suppose you could
get some difference.
But I think-- I'll have
to research judgement,
but my gut is telling
me that there would not
be at a very fine
microscopic level.
In general, though, we draw
it looking much like this.
OK?
Any other questions about this,
about how we constructed it,
using the Anderson method?
No?
OK.
Why don't we continue?
What we've done
right here is fill
in those diagrams, the same
ones that you were looking at,
with many more variables.
The purpose of this
is to get to the point
where we can describe
the built-in voltage.
Remember, we
mentioned that, if we
have some exponential
current voltage response,
there should be some barrier
embedded inside of our system.
And this right here
is that barrier.
So these series of
variables are teaching us
how to derive it,
how to discover
how large that barrier is.
And this other
component right here,
which is the width of the
space charge region, which
is the width of this, so-called,
curved region, if you will,
is also going to
be of importance.
So first off, let's
think about it this way.
If we are looking at this
system from the electron's
perspective, we have
an n-type semiconductor
right here coming up
against the metal.
If our work function
of the metal
is larger than the
work function--
or the so-called work
function of the semiconductor,
which is really the
electron affinity
plus the delta in energy
between the conduction
band of the Fermi energy.
But if the work function of
the metal is larger than that,
we can see that the electrons
should very easily plop down
into the metal.
And there shouldn't be-- let's
see, in that particular case,
work function of
the mental should
result in an Ohmic contact
for the minority carriers,
in that case.
But in terms of
the barrier height,
this barrier height right
here would be determined
by that equation there.
The contact potential,
the built-in bias voltage
would be here, and the
barrier height there.
And the width of the space
charge region, once again,
is dependent on
the dopant density
inside of the semiconductor.
Here, we've defined it
as Nd, because we're
assuming that this is an n-type
semiconductor with donor atoms.
But of course, if this were
a p-type semiconductor,
we'd just replace this with
Na to determine the width.
And if the dopant
density is small,
this means that the width
of the space charge region
is going to be large.
And that makes
sense, because there
has to be an equal
amount of charge
on either side of the junction.
And if there is less charge
per unit volume here,
you need a larger volume
to compensate the charge
on the other side.
So this is, again, a similar
expression to the one
that we saw when we were
studying the PN junctions.
Now, the important
thing to recognize here
is that, if we have the bands
bending this way, for electrons
in our system, there may
be a barrier to hop out.
For holes in the
system, though, this
could be a favorable
exit strategy,
if the bands are bent that way.
If the bends are
bent the other way,
electrons can rather
easily roll down.
But holes will have a barrier
to go out of the material.
So the same type
of metal that might
make an Ohmic contact
for an n-type material
might make a Schottky contact
for a p-type material.
Yeah, that's about it.
So we have to be very careful
in terms of our matching
or pairing between the
specific type of metal
and the specific
semiconductor involved.
Let me put that into
perspective here with something
we've already seen.
Again, the Ohmic contact is one
in which we have a linear IV
characteristic.
And the electron barrier
height has to be less than
or equal to 0, to have the
electrons very easily pop down
into the contact.
Whereas, for a
Schottky contact, there
should be some barrier height.
It should be finite.
And we should have a difficulty
of moving the electron
from the semiconductor into the
metal, in that particular case.
So the natural question is,
what metals should we use?
Or what is the range of
metals that are available?
If the barrier height is a
function of the work function
of the metal, what is the
range of work functions
that are available to us?
On this green arrow right
here, which is Q times the work
function of the metal, we have
a range of different metals,
from aluminum to platinum,
and titanium, zinc, tungsten,
molybdenum, copper,
nickel, gold, in between.
And of course, there
are other metals, too,
in the periodic table that
you can add to this chart.
But this gives you
a sense of where
the Fermi energy of
the metal would lie,
relative to the
vacuum level, and how
that would match up against
your arbitrary semiconductor.
This one here happens to be
a silicon carbide material.
But if you happen to be working
on a different semiconductor
and place it right here, you
can see where your Fermi energy
would lie, relative to the
work function of the metal,
if you line up
the vacuum levels.
And this gives you
an idea already
of how the bands
will bend, once you
adjust the position of the metal
to match up the Fermi energy
inside of your
semiconductor material.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So on the left is
an intrinsic semiconductor?
Is it?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yeah, it's
pretty close to intrinsic.
It's a little n-type,
it looks like.
But it's pretty
close to intrinsic.
This, in this case, just a
variant of silicon carbide.
There are many polymorphs
of silicon carbide,
meaning same composition,
same silicon carbon ratio,
but different
crystal structures,
depending on how it was grown.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Do you know
where silver would fall?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Silver?
AUDIENCE: It's not
listed [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI:
No, it's listed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a lot for [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yeah.
I'm going to have
to guess that it's
going to fall around here,
just from a similarity
of other elemental
species in that list.
Do you happen to remember the
work function of silver, Joe?
Been working with
it a lot lately.
JOE: Yeah.
I don't know.
TONIO BUONASSISI: OK.
Quick, interesting
aside about silver,
since it was brought up.
It is used very often in contact
metallization in solar cells.
As a matter of fact,
a bit too much now.
So much so that it's driving
up the price of silver
on the market.
We talked about this, I think,
in a few classes ago, right?
10%, approximately,
of all silver
worldwide is currently being
used in contact metallization
in solar cells.
That's a pretty high number.
OK, so we have a variety
of metals to choose from,
almost like a menu.
And then the semiconductor
here, and we can see, OK,
if we make contact-- and
let's say we pick nickel,
in this case-- if the
Fermi energies line up,
that means we shift
the metal down.
That means that our vacuum
level is going to fall down here
in the semiconductor.
And for electrons, at least,
will be very easily contacting
this silicon carbide material.
So from a simple energy
band diagram point of view,
we can begin to see which
contacts will create
Ohmic contacts,
and which contacts
will create Schottky contacts.
That's in the ideal world.
In reality-- well, let me
make sure that we grasp this
before we move on.
Any questions
concerning this so far?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How would
we be able to tell
if it's Ohmic or
Schottky in this sense?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Sure.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI: Absolutely.
So from this diagram right
here, let's walk through it.
So if I, say, have a
semicondting-- let's first line
up the vacuum levels, like
we've done right here.
That's a good first
step on, what we call,
the Anderson method
of identifying
with the band diagram or band
structure will look like.
We start with the
vacuum levels lined up.
I'm going to write
to this vacuum.
And I'm going to dray my
semiconductor on one side.
So let's say I have conduction
band and bands bent like so.
And I have my Fermi
energy like so, Ef.
So this is my semiconductor.
And then I have an
imaginary barrier,
and I have my metal
on the other side.
So now, let's say we have
a metal that has a work
function somewhere up here.
So this is the work
function of the metal.
We'll call it the Fermi
energy inside of the metal.
What happens when I put
these two materials together?
Well, step one is to remove
that imaginary barrier
in between them.
And now, you begin
to look at this
and say, well, if
they're in contact,
in good electrical
contact, and there's
no resistance
throughout the material,
the chemical potential
should be identical
all throughout the material,
from left to right.
And so now, I merge into
phase two, which is to say,
I've removed this barrier
here in the middle,
and now my Fermi energy is going
to be equilibrated throughout.
So my Ef is going to
be the same throughout.
And so, far away from
the junction region here
in the middle, I'm going to
draw my conduction band here
and my vacuum level here.
And now, far away
from the junction
on the other side in the
metal, if my Fermi energy
is here and my vacuum
energy is going
to be somewhere
down around here.
So semiconductor and metal.
Now, what happens closer
to the interface right
here-- this is the Fermi energy.
This is the conduction band.
This is the valence band.
This is the vacuum level in
the semiconductor, the vacuum
level in the middle.
And like we just
described, the vacuum level
has to be continuous.
There has to be a
continuity throughout.
And so what we see
here at the interface,
since the density of charge
is very high in the metal,
but lower in the
semiconductor, there's
going to be band bending
at the interface.
And there's going
to be a lot more
bending on the bands
in the semiconductor
than there will be in the metal,
as a result of the difference
in charge densities.
And so what you'll see is
something that looks like this.
The vacuum level will drop as
it reaches that semiconductor
metal interface, in order
to match either side.
And the conduction
band and valence bands
will track the vacuum level on
either side of that junction.
So this is the junction
right here, in between.
And now I look at this
situation right here,
and I say, OK, if I have
an electron approaching
this junction right
here, there is
no barrier to going from the
semiconductor into the metal.
As a matter of fact, there's
almost an energy gain
to be had from going from the
semiconductor into the metal.
But now, from the
hole's perspective,
if I'm a hole right
here in the valence band
and approaching this
junction, there's
actually a repulsion away from
that interface, if I'm a hole.
And so this particular junction
here allows electrons to pass,
but repels holes.
This is looking an
awful lot like a diode.
So it's this
construction right here
that allows you to tell--
asterisk, tell, asterisk,
according to the
Schottky band diagram--
whether or not
this should behave
in an Ohmic fashion
or a Schottky
fashion for the particular
karyotype that you're probing.
And I say asterisks,
because, in real life,
contacts are never that simple.
This is an example right
here of the calculated-- make
sure I get all my
variables right.
Yeah.
So work function in the middle.
The calculated barrier height
for different metal species
here on a certain type, a
certain polymorphous silicon
carbide.
And these are the major barrier
heights for different metals,
titanium, nickel and
gold, at different faces
of the silicon carbide.
So if you have a
binary semiconductor,
meaning a semiconductor
comprised of two elements,
if you terminate at a surface
and you cut the plane just
right, you could wind up
exposing a plane of silicon
atoms or of carbon atoms,
if you have silicon carbide,
let's say, depending
on where you cut.
So if you cut right
here, you might expose
a plane of silicon atoms.
You cut one atomic
layer above, you
might expose a row
of carbon atoms.
Cut a row above that,
it's silicon again.
And so depending on
what face you expose
and depending on the
orientation of that face,
your barrier height, relative to
the metal, could be different.
So, hm.
You glance at that, and you
begin thinking to yourself,
OK, this is
macroscopic right here.
This tells you, kind of
from a continuum point
of view, what the interface
should behave like,
what the context should be.
But what I'm seeing
right here from the data
is that the atomic
configuration at the interface
really matters.
So there must be something
going on in an atomic level,
as well, that's determining
the barrier at that interface.
In fact, there is.
The dipole at the
interface between the metal
and that last layer of
semiconductor, in other words,
the distribution of charge
between those two sets of atoms
that are meeting at an
interface determines, in part,
the barrier height.
We'll get to that in
a few slides, as well.
So this is meant to shine light
on a much broader picture,
which is to say
that there can be
substantial deviations
from Schottky theory
at the interface.
And some of the effects are
due to orientation-dependent
surface states.
It could be due to the
specific elemental nature
of the terminated
surface, as we just
discussed, whether you're
terminating at the silicon
plane or the carbon plane.
Orientation-dependence
means, gee,
if I have an
anisotropic crystal,
meaning a crystal that looks
a little bit different, if I
rotate it around in
different orientations,
if I make cuts in different
directions exposing
different planes, they're
going to be a different density
of atoms in that plane.
There's going to be
a different charge
distribution in that plane.
And hence, I would
expect there to be
some different interaction
between the semiconductor
and the metal at that interface.
And finally, interface
dipoles, this relates back up
to the first one in part.
This just goes to
say that, if I have
an ionic material or an element
there at that interface that
is grabbing charge,
I could result
in a small region
of negative charge
and positive charge
forming a dipole right
there at the interface.
And if I have a buildup
of charge, I have a field.
If I have a field,
I have a potential.
And if I have a
potential, I'm going
to be disrupting this
precise interface right here.
And we can, as well, vary the
density of interface states--
I got you, Ashley, I'll
be there in a second--
so we can, as well, vary
the density of defect states
here at this interface
that can trap charge.
And again, with the accumulation
of charge, comes a field.
With a field comes a
deviation of the potential.
So what we've done for
ourselves is, effectively,
using the Schottky model,
we've set up for ourselves
the energy band diagram of a
metal semiconductor contact
in its simplest case.
And what we're going to do
over the next few slides
is explore some of
the more complexity
behind what goes into a
semiconductor metal contact.
Ashley?
ASHLEY: So going back
that with the green line,
so these metals,
given some [INAUDIBLE]
up there on the left, would all
result in Schottky contacts?
Is that right?
Because all of
their work functions
are above the Fermi level?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yeah.
ASHLEY: Assuming [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI:
So yeah, it depends
on what is the minority carrier
in this particular junction
that's driving it.
Because this is intrinsic,
it's a little difficult to say,
actually.
But if it was clear
there was n- or p-type,
and the minority carrier
density at that interface
was determining the
current flow across it,
then we'd be able to
say with certainty
whether it was one
type or another.
ASHLEY: OK.
TONIO BUONASSISI: But, yeah.
ASHLEY: So if it were--
TONIO BUONASSISI: So in
this case right over here--
let's make it specific.
ASHLEY: Yes.
TONIO BUONASSISI: In this
case right over here,
let's make this an
n-type material.
So my Ef is now higher.
Ew.
OK.
That actually had
the opposite effect.
Let's exacerbate this a bit.
I'm actually going to
invert that and make
this a p-type material.
The reason is I want a big
delta in my Fermi energies
right here, if my vacuum
level is constant,
so to exacerbate that band
bending at the interface.
And so now, I'm going to get
a pretty drastic band bending.
It'll be even more extreme
than what I drew here.
But let's say it's fine.
So what we would have to do
is we would have to move this
down further, right?
Actually, no.
Sorry.
This wouldn't change, because
this is still the same.
What we've done
here is essentially
shifted everything up further.
So to be more precise, we'd have
to move this up, move this up.
And we'd have to move
this up, as well.
Again, p-type material.
Excellent.
And now, again, just
going through the logic
of the process here, we have to
make the vacuum levels match.
And there's going to be
an equal amount of charge
on either side of that junction.
Now, when there's a
charge, there's a field.
When there's a field,
there's a potential.
And the potential
will be manifested
in the bending of those bands
approaching the interface.
The bands will bend a lot
more in the semiconductor
than they will in the metal,
because the free charge
density here in
the semiconductor
is a lot less than
it is in the metal.
And going back to this
equation right here,
the width of the
region of bent bands
is going to depend inversely
on the dopant density
or the amount of
charge in that region.
So this is to say
that we'll have
a much more extreme bending
here in the semiconductor
than we will in the metal.
Virtually imperceptible
there in the metal.
And we drop this down, as well.
So some really
interesting things
have happened right here to the
position of the Fermi energy
in the band gap, right?
Over here, we have
a p-type material.
And over here, at
the surface layer,
it almost looks like this
material is going n-type.
ASHLEY: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Let me
pause right here, because this
is just utterly
fascinating, and tell you
the story about indium nitride.
It's a common material
that many people--
I see a few knowing nods
here in the audience.
So indium nitride was a
semiconducting material
that people really didn't
have a good handle on
for a variety of reasons.
And there was a
renewed interest in it,
because people finally started
to understand why the band
gap was the way it was.
And many groups
started studying it.
And they also reporting
this n-type indium nitride
behavior, very highly
n-type material,
highly doped n-type material.
It turned out that there
was this band bending here
at the surface.
And they were measuring a
high electron concentration
at the surface, because
of the bending of bands.
It was in reality the intrinsic
material deep in the bulk
was p-type.
But they just couldn't see
it because their probes
were touching the
semiconductor at the surface.
It took a certain scientist
by the name of Becca Jones
in Berkeley, Lawrence Berkeley
Lab, I believe, at the time.
She immersed the sample
into a liquid solution
of an acid-- I believe it
was hydrofluoric acid--
and managed to relieve
the pinning of the bands
at the surface.
And so they returned to normal.
And she was able to probe
using a semiconductor liquid
junction, the true
conductivity type
of the bulk of the material.
Becca Jones then went on to
produce what is now the-- oh,
she was on the
team that produced
one of the highest
efficiency cells
on the efficiency
versus time plots.
So she's doing well for
herself there in the PV world.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Sorry.
Sorry.
So let me get back to that.
What would happen if you
were an electron right here
and you were approaching
this junction?
This is E. This is the
energy of electrons.
So the electron will
seek to minimize,
it will seek to encounter
a lower energy state.
So if you're approaching
this junction as an electron,
what would happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI: Zoom.
Yep.
So it's go down.
And there wouldn't be any
barrier for it to do so.
AUDIENCE: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
It would just go,
[MAKES WHOOSH SOUND]
straight down.
Now, let's inverse the
situation and imagine,
what if you're a
hole right here?
What now?
If you think of electrons
as bowling balls
that want to roll
down hills, holes
would be the opposite,
which would be like balloons
that want to rise, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI: And so this is
actually a barrier for a hole.
AUDIENCE: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI: You need
a certain amount of energy
to get the hole across.
And so the hole naturally will
be repelled by this junction.
The hole will want
to go this way.
The electron will
want to go that way.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So this is Schottky for
electrons, but Ohmic-- sorry,
Schottky for holes and
Ohmic for [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI:
Let's imagine we
have a device that is driven
by the minority carrier flux
here at this interface, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI: And so
what is the minority carrier
in this particular case?
AUDIENCE: So the left is p-type,
and so the minority carrier
would be electrons?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yep.
Exactly.
So what would you expect
this contact to behave like?
AUDIENCE: So it'd be Schottky
for-- no, Ohmic for electrons.
TONIO BUONASSISI: So
this one right here,
the electrons would be able
to flow over quite easily.
So in the illuminated case
where the current would
be driven by the
minority carrier flux,
you would expect to see a
behavior without a barrier.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So Ohmic for--
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Now, it
can become a little bit more
complicated, but let's
leave that right there.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
AUDIENCE: If you have a
Schottkys barrier like
that, it's just extracting
electrons or holes,
then is the relevant quantity
on the left a quasi-Fermi
energy for electrons or holes?
Or is it it's always the
overall Fermi energy?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Yeah.
So you raise an
interesting point,
which is the question
of quasi-Fermi energy.
So if you illuminate your
device or you forward-bias it,
what happens?
Now, you start
injecting carriers.
And as we discussed
during class the time,
the total carrier
density is going
to be equal to, let's call
it, the intrinsic carrier
concentration plus
the dopant density,
if this n would be
the density of donors,
plus my delta n, which is the
injected carrier concentration.
So in this particular case--
let's parse this through-- this
is going to be small,
so we can ignore that.
Well, actually, no.
For the electrons
in this case, this
will actually be quite big.
This is going to be
smaller, rather negligible.
And let's think this
through carefully here.
So under equilibrium conditions,
under equilibrium conditions--
let's describe this
as an n0, briefly.
So under equilibrium
conditions, my n0
is going to be rather
small because, if I
have a high dopant density
of p-type material,
that means that my
electron and my n0
is going to be equal to
ni squared divided by p0.
And if p0 is in the order
of, say, 10 to the 16,
ni would be nearer
to 10 to the 10.
We'd have something in the
order of 10 to the 4 for n0.
That would be a
rather small number.
Now, if I inject light
on it, I could have, say,
10 to the 14 electrons
being created.
So this drowns out
everything else.
So now, my electron
concentration
is going to be driven
by the free carrier
concentration, the photo-excited
carrier concentration.
Now, on the p, on
the other hand,
this is going to be
equal to p0 plus delta p.
So let me drag this over here.
The delta p is still on the
same order as the delta n,
let's say, 10 to the 13,
somewhere in that range.
But my p0 is equal to the dopant
density, acceptor density,
which could be on the
order of 10 to the 16.
So this will be somewhere in
the range of, say, 10 to the 16,
driven by the acceptor
concentration.
And so now, I have a
situation in which I have 10
to the 13 electrons and
maybe 10 to the 16 holes.
And if I multiply
the two together,
I'm not getting the intrinsic
carrier concentration
squared, because I'm not
under dark conditions.
I'm not under
equilibrium conditions.
I'm in a steady state condition.
I'm shining light.
I'm exciting carriers.
They're recombining,
but at steady state.
I'm shining light,
generating the carrier again.
And we reach this
quasi-equilibrium.
And so what we have,
at the end of the day,
is a separation of
the Fermi energy
between electrons and holes.
The Fermi energy
for holes is going
to be relatively constant.
But the electrons for
the minority carrier,
you'll have a rise of
that quasi-Fermi energy,
because now you're filling in
more of your electrons up here.
And so the Fermi
energy, as defined
as the energy state that has
a 50% occupancy probability,
is now at a different energy
for electrons or for holes.
Awesome.
It's really one of
those things that
takes a while to really
wrap your mind around.
And so now, we might
have a situation
which my electron quasi-Fermi
energy is somewhere up here.
Let's make it a
little bit-- I don't
want to get into what's called
a two-dimension electron gas.
I'll draw it
somewhere down here.
So now, I have
this distance here
is defined by the minority
current diffusion length,
typically, from the junction.
AUDIENCE: And as
the electrons drop
from that quasi-Fermi
energy to the Fermi energy
of the metal, what happens?
TONIO BUONASSISI: So
the important thing
to think about is current flow
can be reduced to electrons
within the conduction
band, discrete particles
that are seeking to
minimize their free energy.
The voltage or the
potential across
is dictated by the ensemble.
And that's where the Fermi
energies come into play.
So in that particular case,
it might even cause the Fermi
energy over here to rise a bit.
And then you have
a potential across.
If you had a wire connecting
this to an external load,
you'd actually be
able to power it.
The electrons would
be photo-excited
in here, would be driven
over into the metal,
because of the built-in field.
And then they'd be able to
power an external circuit
and come back into the back.
So you're beginning
to see something that
looks a lot like a PN junction.
And in this particular case,
the dark current for electrons
would be dictated by their flow
back into the semiconductor.
So yes, in this
particular case here--
let me correct myself--
in this particular case
here, for the
electron, you would
have a barrier for the
diffusion current, which
would be driven from the metal
into the base right here.
And so the diffusion
current of the electrons
would be facing
this barrier here.
And this would be
Schottky-like in nature.
If you illuminate it,
your illumination current
would-- so let me back
up one step right here.
So in the dark, a completely
dark sample right here,
that I-V characteristic
is driven
by the diffusion current
of electrons to the metal
and to the semiconductor.
And that is, in this
case, with the barrier.
And as you begin
forward-biasing it,
you would have more and
more carriers coming across.
And that would drive the
diffusion current forward.
The illumination current would
be driving the opposite way.
And so, if you illuminated
this entire system,
your blue curve
would shift down.
Let's say, if you're
photo-exciting carriers
within the base right
here, they can very easily
reach the metal.
But if you're putting contacts
and probing the total current
flowing through your
system, in the dark,
you would be measuring
the diffusion current
from the metal into
the semiconductor.
There's some positive
electrons over here.
And so the electrons will
be driven from the metal
into the semiconductor.
And they would be
facing this barrier.
And hence, you would see
a Schottky-like behavior.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So in the dark, it would be
Schottky-like for electrons.
And in the [INAUDIBLE]--
TONIO BUONASSISI:
So you think of it
in terms of total current.
Yes, you're absolutely right.
AUDIENCE: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI: And the holes
would be equal and opposite.
Then, when you
illuminate it, current
would start flowing
the other direction.
So in the dark, the
current is flowing, say,
in the positive direction.
And let's define the
positive direction
as electrons flowing
from here to here,
which means that positive flow
is going from left to right.
So that makes sense.
And when we illuminate it,
now, instead of the electrons
flowing from the
right into the left,
we have the illumination current
driving electrons from the left
and to the right.
So the direction of
current is reversed,
when we illuminate this.
And that's the same
thing as saying,
I'm going to shift this
down under illumination
and wind up with something that
behaves very similar to a PN
junction.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
I thought we said that, under
illumination conditions,
this situation is
Ohmic for electrons.
Or is that not true?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Sorry.
The electrons have no
barrier to travel over here
for the illumination current.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Oh, so this--
TONIO BUONASSISI: So the
illumination current's
going to be constant throughout.
AUDIENCE: So it's-- [INAUDIBLE].
TONIO BUONASSISI: But for
the diffusion current--
the net current behavior, the
net I-V characteristic of this
will be Schottky-like.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TONIO BUONASSISI: But
the diffusion current
is the one that's driving
the current in that case.
And the illumination current
is being driven by the minority
carrier flow right here at the
edge of the metal semiconductor
contact.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Joe,
why don't we flag this?
I sense this is going to
be an item for discussion
during the recitation session.
JOE: Sorry. [INAUDIBLE]?
TONIO BUONASSISI: Just the
metal semiconductor interface,
I think, we're going to
have to go through it
from scratch again.
This is very, very
similar to a PN junction.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
TONIO BUONASSISI:
So I think where
folks are getting tripped
up is thinking about--
and even I sometimes
get tripped up--
is thinking about what happens
to the illuminated current
and what happens to the drift
current and the diffusion
current.
AUDIENCE: Right.
TONIO BUONASSISI: So
it's all very similar.
It's all stuff
we've seen before.
We just have to think
through it step by step
and make sure we don't get
tripped up along the way.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
TONIO BUONASSISI: OK.
So let's talk about some
of the non-idealities
because this is where
the fun stuff lies.
When we have a metal
on a semiconductor,
a lot goes into it.
For example, if we have
interface states or surface
states, we can form band
bending there at that interface.
Let me demonstrate how.
This is an article that everyone
should have read already.
It was part of the
assigned reading today.
And if my past
experience is a guide,
there is a fixed
percentage of you
who haven't seen it
yet, so I'm going
to pass around the article
that you should have read.
So this is something-- feel
free to skim through it,
gain an appreciation for,
really, the spectacular nature
of that article.
And then pass it
around your colleagues.
Make sure everybody
gets to see them.
On the left-hand side, we have
an example of a semiconductor,
let's say, surface.
The surface is represented
by this really large band gap
material right there, that
box, that rectilinear box,
very thin and skinny.
It's thin because the
surface layer is very thin.
It's maybe a few nanometers,
typically, in a semiconductor.
And it's very large
and band gapped
because we formed a
semiconductor and oxide,
let's say, a silicon oxide, a
silica layer at that surface.
So if we have pure silicon
and we expose it to air,
the silicon will react with air
and form a very thin SiO2 layer
or silicon oxide layer.
And that's what this represents.
This is a very large band gap
material, and it's very thin.
And so if there are
no interface states,
if we have an ideal material,
we have our semiconductor
over here and our
surface layer there.
And at that interface, boom.
You just have a discontinuity
in the conduction bands.
And of course, the vacuum
levels are matching up.
But in the case where
you have surface states
at that interface, what happens?
Well now, those
surface states can
be filled by electrons in
the neighboring region.
And as a result, you'll
have a natural band
bending at that interface.
So as you begin filling
in those states,
another way to think
about it is that you're
pulling the Fermi
energy toward mid-gap,
because now, as the
electrons are depleted
from that near-surface region,
as they fall into those surface
states, the Fermi energy is
going to shift towards mid-gap.
And if you indeed look at
the semiconductor, right here
at the surface, you'll see
the Fermi energy is almost
at the mid-gap.
And so this is a very
curious phenomenon that
occurs in many semiconductors.
There's a natural band
bend toward the surface,
depending on the
surface chemistry.
If you have a semi-conducting
oxide forming at the surface,
or if you happen
to be exposing it
to a sulfur based gas
right after you grow it,
and you form some
sulfide at the surface,
the surface chemistry is
very important for dictating
the band bending at the surface.
Why is that important?
That's important because,
when you go ahead and deposit
a metal on top of
it, now, you not only
have to contend with what
the semiconductor is doing,
but what that semiconductor
surface layer is doing.
Now, the situation is
really becoming complex.
So this is meant to
represent right here what
happens when you have
a metal-- in this case,
a semi-conducting oxide
semiconductor interface,
also known as a MOS, metal oxide
semiconductor-- what happens?
Well, in an ideal case,
you would have the bands
bending a certain way.
And then, with the metal
oxide layer in between,
you can have a definite shift.
So what this is meant
to represent right here
is a metal with a
work function that
is larger than the
electron affinity,
and a work function that is
smaller than the electron
affinity.
And so, given what
we've seen before,
given the Schottky method
of producing the band
diagrams here, we would
expect that, in this case,
we would see bands
bending, say, down.
And in that case-- let's see.
No.
In this case, we'd
see bands bending down
in the semiconductor.
And in this case, the
bands would bend up
in the semiconductor as
we reach that interface.
But because the Fermi energy is
pinned by these surface states
here, we have very little
motion of those bands.
And so we wind up in a
case where we pin the Fermi
energy at the surface
and, pretty much,
no matter what metal we
deposit on top of our sample,
we can wind up
with a certain type
of behavior of
the semiconductor,
a certain current
voltage response.
And this can drive
someone absolutely insane
when you're in the
laboratory trying
to get a repeatable
contact and everything
is changing all the time.
And you walk through
the math, and you
know that you should be getting,
let's say, an Ohmic contact.
You walk through the math,
and you derive the energy band
diagram of the interface.
And you go to the lab,
and over, and over,
and over again, you
obtain a Schottky contact.
And it just drives you insane.
The trick is to always use
repeatable surface preparation.
Always prepare
your surfaces using
the same chemistry, the
same way, every single time.
And if you do that, most
likely, in many cases,
you can get rid of this
native surface oxide
on your semiconducting sample.
But if you take your sample
out of the growth chamber
and move it around
in air and then
put it into the
metallization chamber
where you evaporate
your contacts,
you're exposing your
sample to the air.
You'll form some
surface layer on it,
and your contacts
will be different.
There was a colleague
of mine, who's now
a professor at a university.
And during his PhD, I
think he spent about a year
on a problem like this,
trying to make good contacts.
And unfortunately,
contacts, it's
such a basic thing that
it's one of the first skills
to go when the field moves on.
So for example,
people really knew
how to make good contacts
at MIT 30 years ago,
when the IC industry was
the hot topic of the day.
Then, as that phased
out, the knowledge
of how to make good contact
onto silicon disappeared.
There was maybe one
or two professors
who really had that knowledge
embedded in their minds.
And so, when a new
PhD student came along
at Harvard University
trying to make
Ohmic contact into
silicon, there
wasn't anybody he could
go to and talk to.
He didn't know where
to start or who
to talk to, because this
is kind of base knowledge.
It's really fundamental,
instrumental knowledge
that is going to be
infinitely useful.
But it quickly gets lost
when a field moves on,
when the next material
system becomes hot,
or the next topical area is the
key research area of the day.
If you know how to make good
contacts onto a semiconductor,
I guarantee you, you
will find someplace
in industry or
someplace in academia
where you'll be well-sought
out, and that skill
will be put to good use.
Let's talk about this
space-charge region width
very briefly, because
we're running out of time.
We've talked about
this barrier as being
this insurmountable
barrier, let's say,
for an electron to travel
over, in this case,
to get to the metal.
But what happens if we
increase the dopant density
within the semiconductor?
If we increase the dopant
density in the semiconductor,
then the amount of charge per
unit volume at that interface
or per unit thickness at
the interface increases.
So to compensate some buildup
of charge in the metal,
we would need a thinner
region of the semiconductor,
because it's more heavily doped,
because there are more dopants
per cubic centimeter.
And hence, there are more free
carriers per cubic centimeter
as well.
And as a result, the width
of this space-charge region
will decrease.
And if the width of the
space-charge region decreases,
what happens?
This barrier height
still stays the same.
The barrier height doesn't
change, but the width changes.
And what do we know
from quantum mechanics,
if our barrier is very,
very thin or very narrow?
What happens?
Electrons will?
AUDIENCE: Tunnel.
TONIO BUONASSISI: Tunnel.
And that's exactly what
happens right here.
So if we have a very
narrow space-charge region,
we'll have a tunneling
junction, field emission effect,
it's also known as.
And irrespective of
the barrier height,
you will get electrons
moving straight across.
Now, if we have a wide barrier--
represented there at the top--
there is an energy
barrier for the electrons
to overcome before they reach
the metal on the other side.
And so there, we have
a thermionic emission,
which means that you need
to have an excited electron,
thermally excited-- that's
where the name therm comes
from-- so thermally
excited electron,
before it manages to hop across.
And because there's
and exponentially
decaying number of electrons
with higher and higher
energies, we'll get a very
small number of electrons
that can actually make it.
So the thermionic emission
case will, in effect,
manifest itself as a
higher series resistance
than the field emission case.
You can have the same metal
contacting a semiconductor.
But if the dopant
density is changing,
you will make a
better Ohmic contact.
And of course, when
you're actually
trying to measure the contact
resistance here or measure
the barrier height,
you really have
to know this interface
really, really well.
You can measure experimentally.
But to determine
from theory, you
get a good start by
using the Schottky
models we described right here.
But to really nail it, you need
to perform density functional
theory and determine
the charge distribution
across that interface.
It's really the best
way to go about it.
So in terms of
experiment, thankfully,
there are big tables
that we can look up.
If we have a particular
semiconducting material that's
well-studied, we can look
up the contact materials
that would make the best
contacts, and what techniques
we can use to deposit them, what
temperature we should anele at
to form that alloy.
These are very
practical look up tables
that exist in reference
books, trusted websites-- not
any website, but the trusted
ones-- review articles.
But let's say you're working
on a semiconducting material
that's not on this list.
Let's say you're working on
cuprous oxide, for instance,
and you have to
start from scratch.
The best way to go
about it would simply
be to measure the contact
resistance using the techniques
that we described two lectures
ago where we described the TLM
method or the-- sorry, not
much sleep-- the Transfer Line
Method.
So the important
thing here is to know
that you do have a few tools
at your disposal to measure
barrier heights experimentally.
And at the end of the day, you
can obtain precise numbers.
Just going quickly
into heterojunctions.
This is similar to
the Schottky junctions
we've been talking about so
far, Schottky, Ohmic contacts
between metals and
semiconductors.
This, very, very
briefly, is what
happens when a semiconductor
meets a semiconductor.
Not always can you form
a homo-type junction,
meaning not always can you
have n- and p-type dopants
in a semiconductor like silicon.
Sometimes, it just won't
dope both n- and p-type.
And so you have to make contact
with another semiconducting
material.
And for that, we call
it a heterojunction.
And there are three general
types of heterojunctions.
One in which you
have a wide band gap
material on the left, a narrow
band gap material on the right.
The two are in contact
with each other.
And the vacuum levels
line up into such a way
as to wind up with
this band alignment.
Now, let's say I excite
an electron hole pair
in this wide band gap material.
The hole will be
able to move across.
The electron will be
So both the electron and hole
have moved across the junction,
and we have not
separated charge.
So type one, very bad from the
photovoltaic point of view.
Type two, this is more
similar to the PN junction,
what we've seen so far.
And in this particular
case, if you
excite an electron-hole
pair, the electron
will move across
because of the field,
but the hole will be repelled.
And so the type two junction
is actually preferred,
from a photovoltaic
point of view.
Type three junction will
still separate charge.
The electron will move
from the left-hand side
to the right-hand side.
And the hole will be repelled.
But now that the electron has
moved to the right-hand side,
it actually has a lower energy
than on the right-hand side.
So there is no driving force.
There's no voltage built
up for the electron
to go across, outside
of an external circuit
and power and external load.
And so, from a
photovoltaic point of view,
the type three, unless
under very high illumination
conditions, is generally
considered not desirable,
as well.
So the type two junction is
the preferred junction type
for photovoltaic devices.
And yeah, that's pretty much it.
So you can go through the
exercise shown right here
on your own and determine,
for this particular system
right here, what will
happen at that junction.
How will those bands align?
You have the cheat
sheet shown right after.
But an open question
for you is, using
what you know from today where
we first lined up the vacuum
levels, drew out the band
diagrams independently
for material one
and material two,
just like we've done there,
now we eliminate that barrier
in between them.
We put them together, and
we match the Fermi energies.
In other words, this Fermi
energy, Ef 1 has to equal Ef 2.
So there has to be this
shift going on like that.
What happens then?
How will the bands align?
Follow the vacuum level.
That's my best advice
I can give you.
Let the conduction
band and valence
bands follow the bending
of the vacuum level.
And then, from
there, you should be
able to determine the
final structure that'll
look something like that.
But that's a
take-home assignment,
just to see if the concepts
really jelled today.
So what did we learn how to do?
Or at least, what do we have
a greater appreciation for?
We have a greater
appreciation for all
of these different
components, how
to make different
types of contacts
on a material, what they're
good for, and ultimately, how
this band alignment that we've
learned in our PN junction
expropriations can be applied
as well to metal contacts,
and ultimately,
how this can also
be applied to semiconductor,
semiconductor contacts where
we might have two different
types of semiconductors
coming together and
forming a junction.
How do we predict what
the energy band diagram
is going to look like, once
we have our final junction
right here?
And what do we expect that
to mean, in terms of charge
transport across that layer?
So those are the building
blocks, the basic building
blocks that you will need
to be able to predict how
two materials will behave
when they encounter each other
and so that you can
make solar cell devices.
And I think, with that,
we can pretty much wrap up
our fundamentals
portion of the class.
Woo-hoo!
We get to talk about
technologies next.